sierra
is with us sierra is in columbus ohio hi
sierra how are you
hi good how are you dave and chris
better than we deserve how can we help
hey i wanted to ask questions i often
hear you say
sell the car i'm looking at about 200
000 in debt
not including the house our income
is just over a hundred thousand
most half of that debt is student loan
debt um but we
do have about 50 000 wrapped up in um
car debt do we sell both cars and get
two cheap ones do we sell one car
what are we looking at to attack this
set what do you owe on the two cars it's
50 total break it down
uh so we owe 25 on one
25. okay so yeah
yes but the one is upside down yeah well
yeah
so the deal is this one-fourth of your
debt is cars
it will speed up to move way down in car
i mean you get your two five thousand
dollar cars and pay them off it'll speed
this process
up considerable and uh how old are you
guys
yes um i'm i'm in my 30s
my husband is significantly older though
so he's in his fifties
the advantage of doing this is twofold
one is it cleans up the mathematics and
allows you to move forward getting out
of debt much faster
the other advantage is is you are
screaming at the person in your mirror
that when you bought these cars it was
stupid
by selling them absolutely you are
permanently changing the groove in your
brain
i mean you can say this was dumb and pay
them off but when you sell them
you're saying this was dumb that's right
and it changes as you go you remember
that time
that we had two hundred thousand dollars
in debt and we got rid of fifty thousand
cars we're not going back there
never ever again you know but if you if
you you can work your way out of it you
got you know how fast how long does it
take to pay off
a hundred grand or 200 grand making 100
if you do it in 50 000
it's four years if you do it in 75 000
it's three years yep you get a bird
scooter and a skateboard
and start moving stuff changes today
sierra seriously get your life back get
your life back
bird scooter you got to be ashamed of
yourself we need to get some dave let's
ride
no no no no me and you on bird skaters
that's not a good idea this is the dave
ramsey show